the challenges
facing our world are growing all the
time
how do we build stronger economies with
equal opportunities for all
how do we build a sustainable world for
generations to come
how do we protect our cities and harness
the power of technology
for our common benefit in this series
using the latest bloomberg research and
analysis
we will make sense of the problems of
tomorrow
inequality sustainability
urbanization artificial intelligence
the gender gap and in this film the
demographic time bomb
some of the world's biggest economies
italy germany
japan and china are aging
they're running out of workers with
potentially disastrous economic
and social consequences how can nations
deal with volatile demographic pressures
and will these pressures transform the
global balance of power
for decades to come
[Music]
demographics rule the world
the exact combination of young and old
workers and retirees
can determine a country's economic
future
[Music]
every country has a demographic sweet
spot where
the majority of your population is of
working age so they're both producing
and they're consuming great for the
economy
well demographics are very important put
bluntly for advanced economies the more
people there are
the larger the economy is likely to be
and the more power and influence they're
like to wield on the global stage
and that's why the us is a global leader
and it's why european countries club
together
to influence policy on a global level
the population of the planet doubled
twice in the 20th century
meaning the world was able to create
more wealth
so in 1965 there were about 3.3 billion
people on the planet
now it's about 7.3 that's just just 50
years later so that's obviously had an
enormous effect on the productive
capacity of the economy in total
but as well as growing the world's
population is aging
the average age of all the people on
earth at the start of this decade was 32
by the end of this century it will be
42.
[Music]
by 2035 1.1 billion people
will be over the age of 65.
this graying of the planet has
potentially profound
economic implications as the population
ages
it means there are more people consuming
goods and services and fewer people
producing them
so simply there's just a bit less to go
around and overall that means that
economy with an aging population is
going to be growing slower
than otherwise would as aging happens
people are going to save less they're
going to spend more
and that's potentially going to push up
interest rates quite significantly over
the next few decades
and if you look at analysis from former
bank of england economist charlie bean
he says that's about to happen roughly
right now we're just at that inflection
point
where demographics start to push up
interest rates rather than push down
many of the countries with the fastest
growing working age populations
are in africa or southeast asia these
countries are about to enter
a demographic window that is going to be
very
supportive of producing economic growth
india is in the early parts of a
demographic sweet spot where the
majority of their population
is now of working age this really helps
support growth
india right now in 2016
is projected to be one of if not the
fastest growing
economy in the world the demographic
factors are a big tailwind
to that growth but for more mature
developed economies the demographics are
more complex
and potentially very worrying for some
economies
particularly in europe who are extremely
indebted the slowing growth of the
workforce or the shrinking of the
workforce means that those debts become
less sustainable so it actually adds to
pressures that those economies are
facing
and in particular you've got sort of
italy in that camp um
but actually it extends to germany as
well while that's not indebted the the
demographic pressures facing germany are
actually quite significant
these demographic currents can seem
invisible and slow moving
but they affect many of the day-to-day
decisions of our governments
[Music]
i think that decisions may need to be
made do do we accept the fact that
we we do have aging demographics this
will create headwinds to us producing
growth
or do we accept the fact that we need to
accept immigrants
to rejuvenate to make the population
younger
countries that are really old if they
want to solve this problem
has to ask themselves how many
immigrants do you let in before it
actually is
a cultural revolution within your
country the way of life
that you're used to is going to change
demographic trends pose similarly
dramatic problems for workers
as the population is aging it's also
living longer
and healthier lives so the expectancy
probably should be the
people who are able to work will
continue to work for a bit longer
and i think to just simply to maintain
the the
continued growth of living standards for
material living standards we've seen
over the past
50 years or so people will have to work
stephen chan is an expert in
international politics
he thinks current trends in population
point to a very different world to come
a world where even powerful economies
like japan and china
face potentially catastrophic
demographic challenges
over the next half century you are going
to see major demographic
shifts there's going to be major
expansions of population
i think we may well be entering an era
not so much of despair that may come but
certainly an
era to come shortly of great frustration
because of demographic pressures
[Music]
demographic trends are changing our
world
for stephen chan these offer a unique
insight into global economics and
politics
professor chan has taught in north
america europe africa
and asia and has served as a diplomat
and advisor to the uk foreign office
and u.s state department and his
fascination with how movements of people
can affect movements in international
affairs
stems from his own upbringing my parents
were refugees during world war ii
somehow they found their way to new
zealand and they were told by the ship
captain you guys better get out there's
nothing south of here but
penguins so the appreciation of the need
for people to keep moving around the
world that's always been
with me what i find surprising is how
people seem to imagine that you can live
in a world without
demographic shifts
in our globalized world demographics
matter
some countries will have too many people
leading to internal pressures
and migration others will have too few
leading to a shrinking working age
population
there are going to be immense
demographic changes increasingly
disturbing age profiles in many of these
countries
and of course demographic shifts as
populations spill over from one country
to another
the migrant or refugee crisis for
instance is a case in point
and of course there are very very
difficult concerns to do with aging
workforces for instance
not enough young people coming on stream
onto the market
not enough people educated to the extent
that would be required to fulfill the
technocratic requirements
of the future world
[Music]
china the world's most populous country
has grappled with demographic crises for
much of the last 50 years
since the days of chairman mao its
governments have employed differing
strategies to handle the nation's
changing demographic trends
german mar was not the world's greatest
technocratic
planner he would have sudden whims and
almost swings of mood
but i think that there was an initial
very traditional
chinese impulse to become powerful by
having
a very great number of people this is
something which has a cultural
ancestry now in fact it was never
viable to grow beyond a certain point
even during the early years of the
communist revolution
there were vast food shortages
the more people you have the more the
state must provide for the people within
so it's actually a burden to the state
to have too many
people that's why china decided to
review the policy of growing a
population
and of course went completely to the
other extreme to try to restrict
the growth of the population
the one child policy reversed mao's
plans
with dramatic results
china's fertility rate the number of
births per woman per lifetime
was 5.9 in the early 1970s
today it has fallen below 1.6
demographers estimate a country needs a
fertility rate of 2.1 to maintain a
stable population
[Music]
china is now on the edge of a
demographic cliff
with potentially huge social
consequences
i think when we look at china today
we're going to be looking at a
leadership that realizes that continuing
a one-child policy
is going to lead to nothing but
long-term difficulties
particularly when you have an aging
population with no one to look after
them because there's only
one child you don't have as it were a
mass of children
or an extended family with masses of
children who can do
the looking after and then this aging
population becomes a weight
on the aspirations of the younger ones
but the biggest problem is only now
becoming apparent
china's working age population started
to fall
in 2012. the world's second largest
economy
is losing workers
by 2025 there will be 316 million
chinese over the age of 60.
that's almost equivalent to the entire
population of the united states today
in 2015 china abandoned the one child
policy
i think china does have major concerns
for the immediate future and the
medium-term future
you're going to have this interval which
could be as long as 20 years before
these children grow up and are educated
and are able to participate in a more
competitive
workforce so until that happens there's
going to be a drain not only in terms of
having to invest in the education of
these young people
but whether or not the state can support
the older people who are retiring
before the younger generation comes to
economic maturity it can help
look after them
[Music]
[Music]
stephen believes china's demographics
need not be fatal
though growth may be slowing for some
time
the chinese economy continues to grow
perhaps not at
breakneck speed but it has to continue
to grow in such a way that it continues
to provide employment
to people in terms of the chinese impact
on the rest of the world
provided the chinese still have enough
foreign exchange to keep
buying our manufacturers well i don't
think we're going to have a problem and
certainly we're going to continue to buy
chinese manufacturers you can't walk
down a high street in europe these days
without
having no choice but to buy clothes made
in china
china's government is now expecting the
nation's population to peak
in 2020 before starting to fall
in japan the fall has already started
between 2010 and 2015 its population
shrank
by 947 345.
by the end of this century the un
expects the country's population
to fall from 127.1 million
to just 83 million
other estimates suggest the population
could more than half
to just 52 million compounding the
demographic crisis
is culture japan has got a whole
gathering a whole conubation almost of
problems to do with demographic shifts
to do with
an aging population certainly but to do
with all kinds of social trends and
social habits
which no government in japan wishes to
address
the culture of seniority in japan
denies flexibility for younger workers
the very very strict as it were social
customs that inhibit
the full participation of women in the
workforce
further restricts their flexibility and
then
the very very strict rules on when you
can begin taking out your pension
means that people are stuck
unproductively in work they no longer
want to do they don't want to learn new
ways of doing things
and they become as much a drain at work
as they would be to the state if they
left work and
into retirement japan has so far
resisted
turning to one of the great consequences
of and possible solutions to
recent demographic trends migration
i think one of our problems is that we
always thought that globalization would
be on
our terms but now there's a
multi-faceted
globalization where there are pressures
from many many global players
in different parts of the world i don't
think that we're
now going to be able to put the genie
back into the bottle
in terms of greater transit from the
middle east and north africa
to europe that is a phenomenon which i
think is going to remain with
us in one way or another but numbers
will grow numbers will increase coming
from those parts of the world
to europe
several eu countries have their own
demographic problems
the german government expects one-third
of the population to be over the age of
65
by 2060 europe's largest economy
needs to find more workers
[Music]
and those already in work should be
prepared to work longer
and retire later the extension of the
working age is always going to be one of
these big political hot potatoes but
it's not just a case of making people
stay in employment it has to be a
certain
sort of employment how can you create
the kinds of jobs that will not only
give people employment
but keep them employed in a highly
productive fashion
and i mean highly productive in terms of
the expectations
of the middle part of the 21st century
three of the four biggest economies in
the world china japan and germany
are facing major demographic challenges
the choices they make increasing
fertility accepting large-scale
immigration
or delaying their workers retirement
will determine whether they remain among
the most powerful nations in the world
in the decades to come
[Music]
demographic trends are rippling across
europe
the continent's biggest economy is
facing a population crisis
germany has the most over 65s in the eu
the economy is already experiencing
skilled shortages in some areas
at automaker daimler over 100 retired
workers
like emil canil have been re-hired to
plug the gaps
[Music]
i thought his scans personally have
benefited
the program acknowledges that older
workers have valuable skills
also we have in here
[Music]
[Applause]
for more physical tasks daimler has
modified some of its production lines to
make them more sympathetic
to aging limbs
[Music]
daimler expects half its staff to be
over 50 by 2024.
[Music]
whilst german businesses prepare for an
older workforce
elsewhere in europe immigration offers
another way to defuse the demographic
time bomb
this is satriano in italy a town at the
heart of europe's demographic crisis
[Music]
[Music]
italy's birth rate has been falling for
50 years
and is at the lowest level since
unification in 1861
the italian government is now paying
villages like satriano
to take in migrants from around the
world the hope
is that new blood will stem satriano's
and italy's
[Music]
[Music]
the journeys made by many of the new
arrivals like adnan
a testament to the demographic flows
sweeping the globe
foreign
is
[Music]
it's too early to say if this kind of
managed migration will reverse italy's
demographic fortunes
but it has made satriano a livelier
place
and serves as a reminder that
demographic trends have touched every
community
in the world at some time in the past
[Music]
foreign
demographic shifts are occurring all the
time
in every country being able to
anticipate them early enough
is the key to a nation's future
prosperity
you can boil it down this way when you
have
citizens there's two ways they could add
to the economy
they could produce and they can consume
when you have too many people above a
certain age and they leave the labor
force
suddenly you have people in your economy
who are consuming
but are no longer producing this makes
it much
harder for a country to grow governments
that don't have a long-term wise policy
will face demographic consequences or
rather their successes
will face demographic consequences i
think that those countries that
have got policies that are able to
cater for their demographic changes are
the ones that are going to be
successful in the future
[Music]
you